AWARDS SHOWS, AND COULD HE BE
NOMINATED FOR AN ACADEMY AWARD
STILL REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
>> AND JOINING ME IS LEGENDARY
DIRECTOR ROB REINER, AND ROB,
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
AND YOUR REACTION TO WILL SMITH
RESIGNING, AND DOES IT GO FAR
ENOUGH?
>> WELL, THE ACADEMY IS GOING TO
DECIDE IF HE IS BANNED FOREVER
AND WHETHER HE CAN VOTE OR NOT,
AND THESE THINGS -- WHO CARES.
I MEAN, THE ONLY THING THAT
MATTERS HERE IS THAT ONE GUY HIT
ANOTHER GUY, AND YOU CAN'T DO
THAT.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
I MEAN, THE GOLDEN RULE.
DO UNTO OTHERS, AND YOU JUST
DON'T USE VIOLENCE TO SETTLE
DISPUTES.
IT JUST DOESN'T HAPPEN.
SO WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF CRAZY
THINGS HAPPEN IN THE OSCAR SHOW
OVER THE YEARS AND DAVID NIFEN
WAS GIVING AN AWARD AND A
STREAKER CAME OUT, AND THERE WAS
SALLY FIELD SAYING YOU LIKE ME,
YOU REALLY LIKE ME, AND WARREN
BEATTY AND FAYE DUNAWAY
ANNOUNCING THE WRONG WINNER, BUT
THIS IS THE ONE THING AND I HATE
TO USE THE EXPRESSION BUT TRUMP
THEM ALL, BUT IN THE VIOLENCE.
AND IT IS VIOLENCE.
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR IT ON THE
TELEVISION SHOW, ON THE STREET
CORNER, ANYWHERE.
YOU JUST DON'T SETTLE THE
PROBLEMS THAT WAY.
AND YOU KNOW --
>> YEAH.
>> HE SAID THAT HE WAS SORRY,
AND HE IS SHOULD BE.
>> AND NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
AND THERE ARE SO MANY BETTER
WAYS TO HANDLE IT, AND HE COULD
HAVE WALKED UP AND SAID, CHRIS,
DON'T INSULT MY WIFE THAT WAY,
BECAUSE SHE HAS THIS CONDITION,
AND HEY, CHRIS ROCK, AND BEFORE
WE MOVE ON TO OTHER THING, AND
WHAT ABOUT THE OSCAR FOR KING
RICHARD, AND SHOULD HE KEEP IT?
>> OH, YEAH.
THAT IS HIS WORK, AND YOU KNOW,
IN A FILM, AND THAT IS THE
ARTISTIC ACHIEVEMENT IN A FILM,
FINE, LET HIM HAVE AN OSCAR,
BUT, YOU KNOW, HE IS NOT GOING
TO BE PROSECUTED AND THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN THE RIGHT THING, I
THINK.
THE GUY, AND HE HIT SOMEBODY,
YOU KNOW, YOU SHOULD HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT, BUT CHRIS
ROCK SAID, I AM NOT PRESSING
CHARGES, AND THAT IS FINE.
IT IS GOING TO GO AWAY, BUT
WON'T GO AWAY IS THE FACT THAT
IT HAPPENED.
THAT IS GOING TO BE REMEMBERED
FOREVER.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
>> ONE MORE THING THEY DID WANT
TO ASK YOU ABOUT, AND I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW SO MANY FOLKS IN
THE AUDIENCE, BUT WHAT WAS THE
REACTION TO WILL SMITH GETTING
THAT STANDING OVATION WHEN HE
RECEIVED THE OSCAR.
WANDA SYKES COMMENTED ON THIS.
LISTEN TO WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY.
>> FOR THEM TO LET HIM STAY IN
THAT ROOM AND ENJOY THE REST OF
THE SHOW AND ACCEPT HIS AWARD, I
WAS LIKE, HOW GROSS IS THIS?
THIS IS THE WRONG MESSAGE, AND
YOU KNOW, LIKE, YOU ASSAULT
SOMEBODY, AND YOU GET ESCORTED
OUT OF THE BUILDING, AND THAT IS
IT.
WE WERE THE HOSTS.
RIGHT.
SO WE WERE, AND THIS IS OUR
HOUSE, AND WE ARE INVITING YOU
IN, AND WE ARE THE HOSTS, AND WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE CARE OF Y'ALL
TONIGHT AND MAKE SURE THAT YOU
HAVE A GOOD TIME, AND NOBODY HAS
APOLOGIZED TO US, AND WE WORKED
REALLY HARD TO PUT THAT SHOW
TOGETHER, AND SO I AM LIKE -- I
AM LIKE THE INDUSTRY ITSELF, AND
WHAT THE HELL IS THIS.
>> AND ARE YOU AGREEING LIKE
WHAT IS THE HELL WITH THIS?
>> AND 100% WITH WANDA SYKES
LIKE EVERYTHING THAT SHE SAID IS
SPOT-ON.
>> AND I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT THE
SAD NEWS ABOUT BRUCE WILLIS AND
A HOLLYWOOD ICON AND A LEGEND,
AND YOU DIRECTED HIM FOR "THE
STORY OF US" AND STEPPING BACK
FROM ACTING AS HE IS BATTLING
NEUROLOGICAL CONDITION CALLED
APHASIA THAT AFFECTS HIS ABILITY
TO COMMUNICATE, AND HAVING
TROUBLE WITH MOVIE SETS AND DO
YOU HAVE FAVORITE MEMORIES OF
WORKING WITH HIM ON THIS VERY
SAD NEWS?
>> WELL, IT IS VERY SAD NEWS,
AND BRUCE IS A GOOD GUY, AND I
HAVE HAD VERY GOOD EXPERIENCES
WITH HIM, AND ENJOYED WORKING
WITH HIM.
I RECALL THAT WE DID AN
ADAPTATION OF "MISERY" THE FILM
THAT I MADE FOR THE STAGE, AND
HE PLAYED THE PART THAT JAMES
CAAN PLAYED IN THE MOVIE, AND HE
HAD TO HAVE A EARWICK IN THE
EAR, AND HE HAD TO HAVE THE
DIALOGUE FED TO HIM, AND I
THOUGHT THAT WAS STRANGE AND
MAYBE THAT IS THE BEGINNING OF
WHAT HE HAS NOW, BUT IT IS SAD,
AND HE IS GOOD GUY, AND YOU
KNOW, IT IS JUST VERY, VERY SAD.
>> VERY SAD.
OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO HIM AND HIS
FAMILY, AND IT IS AMAZING HOW
HIS FAMILY HAS RALLIED AROUND
HIM, AND PEOPLE LIKE HIS EX-WIFE
DEMI MOORE.
YOU KNOW, ROB, LET ME TALK TO
YOU ABOUT STUFF THAT YOU ENJOY
TALKING ABOUT AND PASSIONATE
ABOUT, AND YOU HAVE DEVOTED SO
MANY OF YOUR YEARS IN CALIFORNIA
TO POLITICS.
I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE STRONG
FEELINGS ABOUT THE JANUARY 6th
INVESTIGATION, AND YOU WERE
TWEETING ABOUT THIS EARLIER THAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL MAREK
GARLAND AND THE ATTEMPT TO
OVERTURN THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT IS IN YOUR COURT
GROWING MOLD AND COVERED IN COB
COBWEBS, AND WHAT DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT THIS IS TAKE ING TOO LONG?
GARLAND SAYS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE IS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND FOLLOW THE FACTS AND
THE EVIDENCE IN WHERE IT LEADS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, I UNDERSTAND THE
FRUSTRATION, AND I, MYSELF, I AM
FRUSTRATED, BECAUSE WE SAW A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
BREAK LAWS, AND WE KNOW THAT
LAWS WERE BROKEN, SO YOU WANT TO
SEE THOSE PROSPROSECUTED, SO I
UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION, BUT
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WAS TO BE, YOU KNOW,
REFURBISHED IN A WAY, AND HAVE
THE DISTANCE BETWEEN BIDEN AND
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, AND THEY
HAVE KEPT THAT DISTANCE, AND I
WOULD LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT DOJ
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND IS
CROSSING EVERY T AND DOTTING
EVERY I, BECAUSE THERE HAS NEVER
BEEN IN THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY A FORMER PRESIDENT
INDICTED FOR FEDERAL CRIMES.
SO, YOU BETTER BE DAMN SURE WHEN
YOU DO THAT, THAT YOU ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO CONVICT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GO DOWN THAT
ROAD, BECAUSE IT IS A POLITICAL
THIRD RAIL, AND IT IS A HOT
POTATO OR WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
CALL IT, BUT I STILL AM HOLDING
OUT HOPE THAT HE IS GOING TO DO
THAT, BECAUSE, YOU CANNOT HAVE A
DEMOCRACY IF YOU DON'T RESPECT
THE RULE OF LAW AND THE
CONSTITUTION.
SO, YOU MAY HAVE POLITICAL
PROBLEMS WITH THIS, BUT IF YOU
DON'T PROSECUTE IT, YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE BIGGER POLITICAL
PROBLEMS IN THAT YOU ARE GOING
TO BE LOSING THE DEMOCRACY, AND
THAT IS THE FEAR, AND I KNOW
THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND IS
GOING TO BE WEIGHING THOSE
THINGS CAREFULLY.
BUT I AM HOPING AT THE END OF
THE DAY, WE HAVE TO SET A SIGNAL
THAT YOU CANNOT BREAK THE LAW,
AND YOU CANNOT TRY TO OVERTURN A
FAIR ELECTION OR TRY TO
OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT, AND IF
YOU DO, YOU MUST BE PROSECUTED